oh my god how the tables have turned
jesus christ
just a few weeks ago in early april 2021
russia was all up in the czech
republic's business rosatom the russian
nuclear agency was set to build the
dukovani nuclear power plant in the
czech republic
a contract worth billions of dollars
it's huge
and russia was set to win it or rather
russia was set to be given the project
by the czech government
russia also had almost 200 personnel in
its prague embassy
which secret services agree is a major
hub for espionage all over europe
for the russian secret services that is
by contrast they have 10 times as much
people in prague than the czech republic
has in russia
as far as embassy staff is concerned and
the czech health minister jan blotni was
fired over not wanting to buy sputnik 5.
he wanted to wait for the european
medicines agency's approval
but this was unacceptable for the czech
republic's very pro-russian president
milor zeman
and he pressured the prime minister
andre babish to fire the help minister
and so he was fired
meanwhile intergovernmental negotiations
between russia and the czech republic
were ongoing for a large purchase of
sputnik 5 which is of course the russian
copied vaccine
the president of the republic mr zeman
controls a delicate political balance in
government
and has a ton of leverage over the prime
minister which he of course abuses the
hell
out of he's also extremely pro-russian
or rather pro-dictatorship in general
and basically spent more time drunk than
i did alive
it was clear something wasn't quite
right with czech president milos
zaiman when he wobbled into prague saint
vitis cathedral
to inspect the nation's crown jewels
after staggering into the room for this
rarest of ceremonies
he needed to prop himself up against a
wall
and someone in general is very good
friends with dictators you know stuff
like the
urger genocide or the ukrainian war
don't really face him
he's still very much russia and china
friendly so this was the situation
a few weeks ago in the czech republic in
early april 2021
russia was eating the czech republic's
lunch while also getting paid by it
billions of dollars and
also being allowed to operate europe's
biggest espionage hub in prague
right and then fast forward two weeks
rosatom was banned from constructing the
dukovan power plant
the czech republic has expelled 18
people from the russian embassy and asks
european and nato allies to do the same
and all plans to buy sputnik 5 are
cancelled
so this is pretty much a complete 180.
so what happened how does a country go
from
limp wristed pro-russian-ness to
attempting to [ __ ] russia over on every
conceivable level
so how did we get here well in the
meantime some very interesting news
surfaced about czech military ammunition
depots
and two russian agents and these
ammunition depots had two things in
common
one they contain weapons to be sent to
the ukrainian army to assist them in
their fight against russia
and two both ammunition depots were
blown up in a sabotage mission
and as announced on april 17th 2021 by
czech prime minister andre babish
both of these sabotage missions were
conducted by the russian military
intelligence or gru
and by the same two agents who tried to
poison sergey skripal in the uk
with the novichok nerve agent and how
nice is that two acts of
state terrorism by the novichok guys on
the european union member state soil
in 2014. which by the way killed two
czech citizens who were both employees
of the ammo depot
and i cannot overstate how big of a deal
this is you know such acts of state
terrorism are just one notch below
just declaring war on the czech republic
and then just bombing them or something
and so the reaction from the czech
government i think was reasonable
and proportional for the most part oh
and you might wonder
how would a pro-russian president get
out of this situation
you know he has managed to find excuses
for all past atrocities of dictatorships
but now it's a bit different you know
now it's a bit closer to home
so what will miller seman the president
of the czech republic say about two acts
of state terrorism which claimed the
lives of two czech citizens
turns out nothing miller zeman said that
he will not comment on the issue for one
week at least
which basically tells you everything you
need to know about his allegiances
you know people like him really worry me
a lot actually
you know people who are friendly to
dictators while also occupying high
positions of power in democracies
and when i say they worry me i mean they
are an existential threat to democracies
and a nice thought experiment that i do
is i think about what people like him
like zemon would do if they would have
access to unlimited power
and they could do what they wanted
without consequences because i'm a firm
believer that power
doesn't corrupt it just enables you to
do what you wanted to do
anyway and what would a person and
people like him do
who are completely okay with dictators
in eastern europe and are good friends
with them
do you think they would be okay with
liberal democracies do you think they
like free speech
or the rule of law well if zemon and
people like him would get unlimited
power magically from tomorrow
you can kiss these things goodbye you
cannot be pro-freedom of speech and you
cannot be pro-democracy
while having friends like vladimir putin
in that case you are either
anti-freedom of speech and
anti-democracy or you just have no firm
values at all
and this whole current system that we
have is just a tool for your cynical
power grab
and honestly i'm not sure which one is
worse
maybe the first one by a little bit
right so i would say please be
wary of these enlightened centrists
advocating for
quote unquote sensible approaches to
eastern dictators
you know we as in people who like
democracy and freedom
will not always be so lucky to have a
state terrorism incident
which changes a country's foreign policy
direction by 180 degrees
so let's not let these people gain a
foothold in government
because remember i'm okay with russia is
code name for
i'm okay with fascism at any rate in
october this year 2021
elections are coming up in the czech
republic where the opposition is set to
win
at least for now at that point we'll
hopefully see the weakening of
pro-russian forces in the czech republic
and consequently in europe further
weakening putin's grip on the free world
thank you for watching please remember
to like and subscribe and to not support
political forces friendly to vladimir
putin and people like him
until then was he drunk
or sick that's the question being asked
of the czech president who stumbled
through a recent public appearance
his office insists he was suffering from
a virus but footage of milos demon
has since gone viral stuart gerr has
more from the czech capital
it was clear something wasn't quite
right with czech president milos
zaiman when he wobbled into prague saint
vitus cathedral
to inspect the nation's crown jewels
after staggering into the room for this
rarest of ceremonies
he needed to prop himself up against a
wall as the 700 year old emerald
encrusted crown
of bohemian king charles iv was placed
on the altar
zaman whose post is largely ceremonial
appeared to be struggling to keep his
balance
and his eyes open his swaying back and
forth
caught the attention of the concerned
czech prime minister next to him
the 68 year old hard drinking chain
smoking head of state
makes no secret of his boozing in the
past he has extolled the virtues of
alcohol
and during elections it was joked his
campaign bus ran on becca rafka
a popular czech liquor but this time his
office
insists he was not drunk he just had a
virus
but